Let's first briefly review
the WiFi technology.
A typical use of WiFi is to
allow personal computers or
devices enabled with WiFi
in a locale such as a home
to access the Internet through
the access point, or AP.
The AP connects to these
devices wirelessly.
And connects to the Internet
through physical wiring.
Such as to a router provided by
the Internet service provider.
Devices in a locale can also connect to
each other wirelessly through the AP.
In wireless networking, data is not
transmitted via physical wiring.
Instead data is transmitted in
air which is an open medium.
In other words, there is no inherent
physical protection of communications.
Also since there's no hard wiring
connecting two devices for
direct communications,
in wireless networking,
communication between two devices is
achieved by one device broadcasting and
the other device listening
to the broadcast.